19.7 billion dollars that was Exxon
mobil's profit last quarter nearly
tripling over a year U.S competitor
Chevron and Europe's shell and total
energies also reported bumper earnings
as Russia's war in Ukraine continues to
push up Energy prices and winter demand
soars the price of crude oil has gone
sharply higher the price of natural gas
has gone sharply higher and the
economics of refining crude oil into
products like gasoline and diesel fuel
has also improved dramatically U.S
President Joe Biden has been pressuring
energy companies to use their earnings
to expand production but shell Exxon
Mobil and others have announced much of
the Bonanza will go to shareholders with
ExxonMobil CEO saying Friday there has
been discussion in the U.S about our
industry returning some of our profits
directly to the American people that's
exactly what we're doing in the 4 form
of our quarterly dividend
immediately after the announcement Biden
tweeted can't believe I have to say this
but getting profits to shareholders is
not the same as bringing prices down for
American families
and more pain is expected in November
when the global oil supply will lose 2
million barrels a day thanks to cuts
from OPEC plus the average price for a
gallon of gas in the U.S is now
3.76 that is down from its peak but
still high for the average American and
that has the White House worried I blame
it on poor
management
and
Outlook uh generally by our government
and
by poor management of the economy with
the U.S midterm elections just days away
Democrats fear high gas prices will cost
the party its control of Congress Biden
has vowed consequences for Saudi Arabia
for going through with the OPEC cuts and
he's releasing 180 million barrels from
the U.S strategic petroleum Reserve to
ease price pressures but Biden has
resisted calls for the U.S to join
Europe in imposing windfall taxes on the
energy sector's profits soaring higher
than ever before Heidi Joe Castro Al
Jazeera Washington